this picture from a high school football
player right here is going nuts right
now the guy in the red jersey is listed
at 64 and 215 lb which means the
offensive lineman is even bigger than
that as a high schooler so who is he
meet Byron Big Baby Washington who's
listed at 68 and 380 lbs and guess what
he's still a junior at doto high school
and is catching everyone's attention but
Byron's story becomes even more
inspirational because of how close he
was to not being able to play football
again back in Middle School Byron had a
massive grow spurt but it actually
became a serious medical issue he had to
get metal rods in his legs to help
support his body had that not happened
he would have risked his gross plates
collapsing but after learning how to
walk normally again he's now dominating
the field Byron already has offers from
Texas TCU Oregon and Arizona State but
at the rate he's going we know he'll be
one of the more coveted prospects
entering College once he graduates